hacking arts
is a festival and hackathon exploring
the intersection
of art entertainment technology and
entrepreneurship
i come from a company called little sun
but also from a work of art that's
called little sun and a global project
that we would call little sun
it's based on the simple but astonishing
fact that 1.6 billion people in the
world don't have access to electricity
the sun goes in the top here and then
you have a little lamp
that shines in the night you can take it
traveling you can take it walking you
can take it everywhere
some people adopt it as arts and we'll
take it as design some will just take it
as a lamp and others will take it as a
symbol of positive access to energy
it's about emotions beauty and
participation what parts of africa have
you been already operating in we're
operating in ethiopia kenya uganda
zimbabwe senegal and south africa with
the hackathon you get the chance to
to work on something you know change it
see it in a different way
make it simple simplicity is crucial the
idea should be like an elevator pitch
really
look at that i like that little drop
little sun
connection there that's really striking
we pass water through a tube that's
exposed to the uv light
and it basically cleans out all the
bacteria in the water
you can see that water is kind of going
this way so you have the two leds and
you have the
led that kind of powers them what we're
proposing
is a community that's centered around a
website that's going to
help the people who are involved in
selling and distributing middlesen to do
three things
to explore to connect and to join we
ended up having a pretty even split of
entrepreneurs artists and engineers
we started out with just totally
bouncing off ideas and going super
divergent and then
whittling it down and now we're finally
getting into like actually building a
prototype
but how amazing have the last two days
been are you guys having fun
i'm really curious to see the
community-based studio because that
could be an interesting part
of exactly this the communication is
really a vital thing hi everyone my name
is chris
i'm maria and we are part of little sun
community
this is a platform which connects
vendors to one another
to allow them to explore connect and
also
join a community have you made art with
little sun
have you found a practical use for
little sun or have you found it a cool
way of making it your newest fashion
accessory
a lot of those people in those very same
communities need something else
they need clean drinking water this
is little drop it's a solar-powered
led water treatment device the straw
spools through some germicidal uv led
light bulbs what the little drop
provides like the little sun
is an emotional experience so you
differentiate yourself
from the ones that are on the market by
it's more of an emotional connection
have you ever heard the light of the sun
so basically we're hearing the light
transforming that into an audio device
something you guys just did like over
the last 48 hours it's like
extremely simple directly wiring up to
this
for this headphone jack the thing i find
really impressive about hackathons
is people really kind of come in and
they're just they're so completely open
to making
totally new connections and then
spending a lot of time working on
something with someone who they just met
the prize goes to the sun community team
thank you for coming
you